[Müzik]
Teşekkürler Merhabalar
şimdi sizi
1992-93 öğretim yılına götürmek
istiyorum o zaman Lise sonda öğrenciyim
üniversite sınavına Hazırlanıyoruz bir
gün öğretmen geldi dedi ki çocuklar
TÜBİTAK olimpiyatlarına okulumuzu
temsilen en iyi öğrencilerimizi
göndereceğiz
Neden bilmiyorum lise 2'de bizde
biyoloji dersi yoktu o yüzden
matematiğin en iyi öğrencileri belli en
yüksek notları almış işte fiziğin belli
ama biyoloji Gönül Esas gönüllük
esasıyla yapılacak biz hemen sorduk
nasıl olacak et trenle gidecek Harika
bir program güzel bir otelde kalacak
Bütün masrafları okullar karşılıyor biz
hemen 4-5 Kafadar organize olduk dedik
ki hocam biz biyoloji aşığıyız
Biz gitmek istiyoruz olimpiyatlara hiç
alakamız yok Biz amacımız güzel bir
hafta sonu geçirip
eğlenmek
isimlerimiz yazıldı gün geldi Ankara'ya
gittik işte
amacımıza ulaştık diyebilirim Ankara'da
olan Ankara'da kalır ama
bugün çok Veli olarak Tasvip etmeyeceğim
ama çok eğlendiğimiz bir hafta sonu
geçirdik şimdi o gün
Tabii kamptan kaçmışız gece 3'te otele
Geri dönmeye çalışıyoruz Yakalandık
büyük bir fırça işte ne biçim
öğrencisiniz Siz sizden hiçbir şey olmaz
Bugün o 5 kişiden bir tanesi benim bir
tanesi gene bir firma sahibi çok
başarılı bir tanesi ülkenin ilk 100
şirketinden bir tanesinin finansasının
başında Muhtemelen 4-5 milyar doları
yönetiyor bir tanesi Doktor olsun
tamamladı Profesör olmak üzere şu an bir
tanesi Amerika'da çok büyük bir yatırım
sonunda Tepe yönetici olarak çalışıyor
daha sonra
lisede çok böyle hep
potansiyel var ama bir de çalışsa
tadında bir öğrenciydim daha sonra
bir şekilde İstanbul Teknik
Üniversitesi'ni kazandım orada da ilk
kazanınca böyle bir ilk Coşku ilk bir
yıl derslerim Fena değildi o kazanmanın
hevesiyle şey yaptım ama baktım ben
aslında mühendis olmak istemiyorum Şimdi
sistemimizde çok büyük bir sorun var
orada okulu bitirdiğim zaman senin
matematiğin fena değil seni fen sınıfına
yazıyor dediler iyi dedik zaten 13-14
yaşında çok bir bilinciniz yok ama bu
sefer fen sınıfından lise sonunda
geldiğiniz zaman
doktor mu olacaksın mühendis mi
doktorluk çok uzak geliyordu İyi dedik
mühendis olacağız bari ya sistem
otomatikman benim mühendis yaptı ama ben
ilk seneyi okuduktan sonra gördüm ki ben
Mühendislik yapmak istediğim şey değil
bir şekilde tabi kendi kendime
yakıştıramadım okumamayım üniversiteyi
bitirdik sonra Hadi bir de yüksek lisans
yapalım
yüksek lisansta farklı bir alan seçtim
işte iş İdaresi
ekonomi pazarlama böyle derslerin
içeriği yüksek lisans programı seçtim
kendime ve
O hep böyle beşten şaşma 6'yı aşma 4'e
yanaşma modundaki öğrenci İşte en arkada
oturan işte müzik Big yakmayı marifet
sanan işte yoklama kağıdına imza
attıktan sonra dersten kaçmaya çalışan
öğrenci gitti
en önde oturan
örnekle ödevler hazırlayan işte Pazar
analizi böyle yapılır görün gibi
hocalarla Hatta işte sürekli sorulan
soru hatta hiç unutmuyorum Bir keresinde
bir konu vardı tam merak ettim ders
çıkışını hocanın yanına gittim soru
sordum
dedi ki şu an vaktim yok bu konu derin
bir konu eve gitmem lazım işim var dedim
ki gelirim eve yolda anlatın
şimdi
Bakın aynı öğrenci arada var 5-6 yıl
birisi harita modu bir tanesi hocanın
evine kadar kovalıyor aradaki Tek fark
bu kadar davranış değişikliğini yapan
şey seni heyecanlandıran
tutkunun keşfi ve heyecanlandıran
konunun bulunması
O yüzden hani sistemimiz bizi
otomatikman beni sayısalcı yaptı ama
belki de ben sözelciymiş
Napolyon'un çok güzel bir sözü var
bütün rütbelerinde aynı ruhu Taşıyan
Ordu
Savaşı kazanır diye
o gün biz Ankara'da 5 kişilik bir
ekiptik Hep Aynı kafada o insanlar
organize olduk emin olun aramızda
gerçekten biyoloji aşığı birisi girseydi
Bizim otel odasında yaptığımız şamatayı
bozacaktır Belki de yani Ama Aynı kafada
aynı vizyonda insanların bir araya
gelmesi Hele bir de tutkunun da nasıl
davranışı değişikliğine yol açtığını
gördünüz çok iyi sonuçlar yaratabiliyor
şimdi şirketlerimize geldiğimiz zaman
Aslında bu tutkulu insanlar ortak Vizyon
dediğimiz şey hep kültür adı altında
tanımlanıyor ve bu kültür kültür
yazılıyor çiziliyor bunun ne kadar
önemli olduğunu nasıl anlatırım diye
size
araştırıyordum düşünüyordum bir gün
internette kaza ile gezerken eski bir
Gazi koşusu'nun sonuçlarını gördüm ah
dedim tamam aradığımı buldum
birinci gelen at
üçüncü gelen atın tam 5 katı para ödülü
almıştı ve ikinci gelen atın da tam 3
katı para ödülü almıştı şimdi
düşünürseniz
birinci gelen at ikinci gelen atı 3
katımız hızlı koştu
iki katımız hızlı koştu
%50 mi daha hızlı koştu
yüzde 10 mu daha hızlı koştu Ben size
söyleyeyim Bir burun daha hızlı koştu
pazarları analiz ederseniz sektörler
aynı sektörde rekabet eden firmaların
ürünlerinin arasında
inanın bir burun fark var ama
skorlarına baktığın zaman bilançolarına
firma değerlerini birkaç misli aynı
yarış atı örneğinde olduğu gibi farklı
olabilir o bir burun fark
yaratan şey işte şirketlerdeki kültür
Gerçi düşün herhangi bir aynı sektörde
rekabet eden ilk iki firmayı düşünün iki
tane cep telefonu 2 tane arabanıza
taktığınız lastik iki tane Seçtiğiniz
gömlek ne kadar fark var aralarında ama
firmaların değerlerine baktığımız zaman
birinci ile ikincinin arasında birkaç
misli fark olabilir
ve
bunu firmalarımızda yaratan şey ve
tanımlaması zor olan şey de kültürdür
şimdi bu kültürü yine yazılıyor
çiziliyor inşa etmesi çok zor
direkt reçeteler bulmak çok zor Ben
kendimce Yarattım bir reçetem var Onu
siz de paylaşmak isteyeceğim
birinci temel
mutlu çalışanlar yani
gene dergileri açsanız röportajlar
yapsanız bütün ceo'lara Tepe önde
çalışanlarımız çok önemli çalışanlar
şöyle çalışanlar böyle
anketler yapıldığında gerçek durum şu an
çalışanların %85'i mutsuz olduğunu
söylüyor iş yerinde fikirlerine değer
verilmediğini söylüyor işte kendini
değersiz hissettiğini söylüyor 8 kişiden
7'si Ben iş yerinde iyi değilim diyor
Halbuki mutluluk o kadar temel bir hak
ki yani
ailemizden çoluğumuzdan çocuğumuzdan
dostlarımızdan çok daha fazla bir süre
iş arkadaşlarımızla geçiriyoruz o
ortamda bu mutlu olmamak çok büyük bir
sosyolojik sorun yani gerçekten bizi
yönetenler de bunu talep etmemiz gereken
bir hak ve mutsuz bir ortamda Bir de
bizden performans bekleniyor
olması gereken şey
gerçekten hem insani değerlerin hem
performans sorumluluk kültürünün bir
arada yaratıldığı bir
ortam yaratmak ama ikinci önemli temel
taşı şirket içi iletişim ve bilgi akışı
şirketinizi yaşayan bir organizma olarak
görürseniz şirket için iletişim ve bilgi
akışının kalitesiz sinir sisteminizdir
yaşanan şey çoğunlukla su şu mesela
vücudumuzda şey yapalım sıcak bir
yüzeyde düşündüğünüz dokunduğunuz zaman
ne olur diyelim ki dokunuyorsun bu el
yanıyor şirketlerimiz olan şey şu bu
bilgi bu kadar hızlı gitmiyor onaylar
mekanizmalar vesaire bu
buradaki yangın devam ediyor ve felçli
bir yapı yazışıyorsun doğada olan şey
nedir Hemen kendini çekebilir burada bir
şey daha var Bazen de el yanıyor ama
daha önce eli yandığı için yani sorun
yaşayan bir ekipten insanlar kovulduğu
için küçük düşürüldüğü için işte toplum
içinde iğnelendiği için vesaire sorunun
üstü de örtülmeye çalışıyor Bu da
felçli bir yapıya doğru götürüyor
şirketlerimizi şimdi bunun çaresi şirket
içinde bir korkusuzluk
garantisi yaratılmalı yani kimse
yaptığı bir şey yüzünden işini
kaybedeceğinden dolayı endişe etmemesi
lazım ki
rahatça bir sorun olduğu zaman yardım
isteyebilirsin üstünü örtmesin bizim
sorunları çözebilmemiz için tek
ihtiyacımız olan şey aslında çok basit
çıplak gerçek ama insanları bunu örtmeye
ya da kibar yollarla başka isimler takıp
daha iyiymiş gibi göstermeye çalıştırdı
çalıştığı bir ortamda gerçek şeye
ulaşamıyoruz gerçek Bilge ve çözüm
yaratamıyoruz churchill'in çok güzel bir
sözü var diyor ki başarı
tutkunuzu kaybetmeden başarısızlıktan
başarısızlığa koşma becerisidir diyor
şirketlerde işleri işlerde sürekli
hatalar olacak aksilikler olacak ama
sizin sonuçlarınızı bir ilerleyen şey o
sorunlara verdiğiniz tepki her
şeyde çok kolay Tabii ya gönderin Bunu
bana yapın şunu işte Nasıl insanlarsınız
Siz demek çok çok kolay Halbuki
hata yapmak kabul edilebilir ama hatadan
öğrenmemek kabul edilemez bunu
yerleştirdiğiniz zaman felçli bir
yapıdan ulaşıyorsunuz Bir de bu ele bu
inisiyatifi vermek lazım bu insanlara
fikirlerine değer vermek lazım bu insan
yandığını hissettiği an kendini
çekebilmeli zaten bilimsel olarak da
böyle İnsan vücudunda çok sıcak bir
yüzeye dokunduğunuzda beğeni sinyal
gitmez el kendisi O refleksi
gösterebilir
bizim hatayı Borak diye bir
şirket içinde kuralımız var
hatalar sadece hatayı yapana
söylenecektir ve hatayı yapan hariç
herkese değil ve hatayı moratmak için
söylenecektir kişiyi aratmak için değil
bir kuralımız daha var Mazeret yok diye
Bunda West minister mezunu bir askeri
akademinin yazdığı yönetim kitaplarından
almıştım ve ismini asgari akademide
Subaylar üstlerinden Emir şu şekilde
alıyorlar Evet efendim diye değil
Mazeret yok efendim
çok güçlü bir şey ekiplere bu mazeret
yok kültürünü sorumluluk kültürünü
yüklemek lazım Onlara Başarılı olmaları
için her türlü ortamı yapmak lazım ve
onlara o insiyatif verdik hata
yaptıklarında da onların
kararlarına ya da onların kararlarına
saygı vermeyi öğrenmemiz lazım
şirket içindeki fikirler ve Hiyerarşi
behçetolojinin anlattığı gibi
tamamen Liyakat Bey bu bazda olması
lazım mevki makamdan bağımsız bir
şekilde kimin Fikri daha iyi ise onun
toplantıda adil bir şekilde fikrinin
yapılabilmesi oldu birçok ortamda bazen
bir uzman Asistan Genel Müdürlüğünde
konuşamaz bile hali oluyor bunun Kore
Hava Yollarında Bir meşhur bir hikayesi
var en modern uçaklara sahip olsalar
bile en yüksek işte hatalı yeni işte
çeşitli Hatta uçak kazası oranları Kore
Hava Yollarında Bir dönem bakıyorlar
bakıyorlar sebebini bulamıyorlar en
sonunda buldukları şey şu; Kore'de o
kadar bir hiyerarşik kültür var ki
ikinci pilot Hatalı gördüğü şeyi birinci
pilota söyleyemiyor ve bunu açtıkları
zaman
bütün istatistikleri ilerliyor çok güzel
bir formülün var Benim Acı artı düşünme
eşittir ilerleme diye ne zaman birisi
Tolga Bey bir sorunumuz var diye gelse
ben mutlu oluyorum Demek ki bir sorun
ortaya çıkıyor konuşuyoruz tartışacağız
onun üzerine düşüneceğiz ve şirket
ilerleyecek şirketiniz ne kadar
ilerleyecek
kaç kişiyi Napolyon'un sözünü unutmayın
bütün ordularında aynı rütbeyi olan aynı
ruh Taşıyan Ordu Savaşı kazanır ne kadar
kişi O acıyla dertleniyorsa düşünce
üretiyorsa o kadar çok düşünce
üretilecek o kadar hızlı acılar
çözülecek ve şirketiniz ilerleyecek
Evet gelişim öğrenme çok önemli bu açık
iletişim
birçok kültürde göremediğimiz için biz
genelde çok genç İnsanları işe almayı
çoğu zaman ilk işi bazen ikinci işi
tecrübeli arkadaşları aldığımızda oluyor
ama çok seçenek alıyoruz çok o
testlerimizi yaparak alıyoruz o
travmatik toplantılarda konuşamama ya da
işte üstünü kalkması sahte kibarlıklar
öğrenmiş kişilerin o alışkanlıktan
kurtulması çok oluyoruz biz kendi
kültürümüzde yorulsunlar istiyoruz o
yüzden
gelişim ve öğrenme bizim yarattığımız
kültürün çok önemli bir farkı her hafta
mutlaka eğitim yaparız öğrenen
öğretimlerimiz var kitap gecelerimiz var
Çok büyük bir kütüphanemiz var işte
Master programlarını sponsor olduğumuzda
dersler var işte Çevik şirket böyle
oluyor çalışanlar Bilgi Küpü yapmaya
çalışıyoruz ve onlara karar verme en ön
cephede karar verme yetkisi veriyoruz
hemen kendisi yapabilsin diye
kararlarını verebilsin diye ve insanlar
da bundan keyif aldığı için mutlu
oluyorlar şimdi bu son temel 5 seviye
liderlik
şimdi lider deyince Böyle karizmatik
işte Genius her şeyi bilen bir şey
gününüzde canlanabilir 5 seviye liderlik
Aslında Bunun tam tersi mütevazi delege
eden insan yetiştiren radikal bir
şekilde başkalarının fikirlerine açık
fikirli radikal bir şekilde dürüst ve
şeffaf Yani hep böyle bazen görüyorum
yönetim kurullarında bir şeyler oluyor
Bütün Ekimin haberi yok kopuk bize bir
açıklama yapılmadı yani sürecin içinde
değil bu yönettiği liderlik modelinde
kurallar da yok ilkeler var değerler var
çünkü kurallar olduğu zaman şöyle bir
ekip yaratıyorsunuz Yapacak bir şey yok
sistem böyle yönettin böyle talimat
verdi ve bu müşteriler için çok sıkıcı
oluyor satışlar düşüyor Ve o insanlara
ilkelerinizi değerlerinizi tanımlayıp o
çerçevede karar vermesine
sağlayarak hem insanların keyif almasını
mutlu olmasını hem de müşter çok iyi bir
hizmet almasını sağlıyorsunuz
Tabii
bütün bunları bağlayan bir temel var o
da sevgi
insanlara değerli hissettirmek çok
önemli bu sistemde ki onlar
kendilerini değerli hissedip bu Firma
için değer Bana verilen değer için diye
değer diyerek O bir burun farkı atacak
yaratıcılık hizmet Güleryüz işte hızlı
çözüm anında çözüm o kahramanlıkları
yapacak insanları
samimi bir olarak sevmeniz lazım Çünkü
hepimiz sosyolojik olarak evrim geçirmiş
canlıları Biz de bize bir şey yaklaştığı
zaman
yıllardaki evrimde ısıracak mı
kovalayacak mı tehlikeli mi onu şey
yapabiliyorum birisi bize gerçekten
severek samimi davranıyor yoksa biz de
işte yapmacık güzel laflarla işini mi
gördürmeye tanıyor anlıyoruz Bunu o
yüzden beşinci bir seviye Lider olmak
istiyorsanız kendinizi sevmeniz lazım
işinizi sevmeniz lazım çalışma
arkadaşlarını sevmeniz lazım misyonunuz
lazım İş yolu hayatı neden bu kadar
hoyrat bilmiyorum ama daha çok sevgi
olsun isterim bugüne geldiğimiz zaman
galiba metal
demir çelik gibi çok sermaye yoğun bir
sektörde
sermayemiz yoktu biz kurulduğumuzda
binamız yoktu makinamız yoktu bir
patentimiz bir desteğimiz herhangi bir
şeyimiz yoktu işte 3 kişi 30 metrekare
kiralık bir ofiste bir şeyler alıp
satarak başladık bugün
işte Türkiye'nin en hızlı büyüyen 48
firması diye bir ödülü aldık vergi
sıralamalarına girdik ilk
bebeğin ihracatçı ve sanayi firmalarının
arasına girdik işte 90'ın Üzerinde
ülkeyi ihracat yapıyoruz işte bir grupta
5 firma oldu İki tanesi yurt dışında
Almanya'dan bir yatırım aldık bu
uyguladığımız prensiplerle
Belki de 40'a 50 yılda gelinebilecek bir
yolu Biz son 10 yılda uyguladığımız
prensiplerle 10 yılda geldiğimizi
düşünüyorum
Bir sonraki 10 yıl bizim ekip nereye
götürür firmayı Bilmiyorum her zaman
beni çok olumlu anlamda şaşırtmışlardır
biz bu prensipleri uygulamak hem
eğlendik hem sonuç aldık
Size de tavsiye ederim Çok teşekkür
ederim